le vaccin d'astrazeneca n'inspire
décidément pas confiance aux français et
les doses ont beaucoup de mal à
s'écouler
aujourd'hui il est utilisé à 60% contre
90% pour le faiseur ou le modern à un
échec dû aux nombreuses polémiques
autour de son efficacité de ces effets
secondaires ainsi qu'à sa suspension
dans plusieurs pays européens
de quoi dissuader une bonne partie de la
population
et pourtant la livraison de ce vaccin
continuent d'affluer la france attend
près de 4,5 millions de doses
d'astrazeneca d'ici fin juin
mais alors que faire de toutes ces doses
une fois livré ses vaccins deviennent la
propriété des états mais l'union
européenne n'est jamais bien loin pour
surveiller la destination des stocks et
pour éviter toute perte la solution
serait et que les doses excédentaires
soient donnés ou revendus à des pays
tiers
l'europe a déjà décidé à qui elle allait
donner les doses boudé par ses
concitoyens aux pays les plus pauvres
notamment en afrique
nombre de doses ont d'ailleurs déjà été
données au programme kovacs kovacs et un
système mis en place par l' oms pour que
les pays les plus riches participent à
la distribution des vaccins aux pays
pauvres à ce jour 72 millions de doses
ont été livrées dans 126 pays bien ce
dispositif
en avril la france avait elle même donné
quelques cent mille doses d'astrazeneca
aux pays africains
mais malgré l'élan de générosité des
européens à l'urgence de la situation
les pays africains aussi ne semblent pas
tous convaincus de l'efficacité du
vaccin en effet pourquoi envoyer de
l'astra zeneca pour soigner des
populations africaines plutôt jeunes
alors qu'en europe ce même vaccin est
déconseillé au moins de 55 ans la
république démocratique du congo par
exemple a reçu en mars dernier 1,7
million de doses d'astrazeneca
mais le pays a retardé le début de sa
campagne suite aux doutes sur ses effets
secondaires qui émergeait en europe
le soudan du sud lui a dû renvoyer 72
mille doses du même vaccin à cause des
réticences de sa population
idem pour le malawi qui a dû détruire
seize mille doses d'astrazeneca dont la
date de péremption était dépassée
l'autre solution c'est la revente elle
permettrait de limiter les pertes
financières et de négocier des tarifs
plus bas reste à savoir qui serait
preneur des doses d'astrazeneca
alors que l'union européenne qui n'a pas
renouvelé ses commandes
astrazeneca fait don de ces doses à
l'afrique un laboratoire s'affirme déjà
comme le grand gagnant de ce désamour
céphise heures qui vient de signer avec
bruxelles
un troisième contrat pour l'achat d'un
virgule 8 milliards de doses